- Well, speaking of sex lives,
Um, you've posted this...
Let's show them.
(giggles)
[Kelly] It was like, So you, you said,
"Joey and Chandler were
your sexual awakening."
- [Mandy] Yes.
- You know, I would say
explain, but I am you.
I loved friends. I loved, I mean.
- I love friends.
Well, look at this photo
of the two of them, right?
This is like-
- I'm in.
- Peak, peak Matthew Perry.
- Yeah, yeah-
Peak Matt LeBlanc.
- Yeah.
- And during, when they had
the, the Friends Reunion-
- Yeah.
- On HBO Max, like-
- [Kelly] Uh, did I watch it? Yeah.
And was I like freaking
out the Rachel and Ross
secretly had this like weird
chemistry thing in real life?
- Yes. Exactly. Yes.
- Yeah.
- And so when they did that,
there was lots of memes of when they were,
you know, in their twenties
and they were posting
it and I saw that photo
and I was transported
back to being 14 year old.
14 years old and just
being like, oh my gosh,
if only, if only Chandler
was my boyfriend.
And I saw that photo and I was like,
"this is my sexual awakening."
(laughing)
Well it felt like, it was for,
you know, cause I'm like 40.
So for me, like, I'm
like the perfect age for-
- [Kelly] Me too, I'm about
to be 40. Yeah, yeah yeah.
So it's like our perfect age.
That and I loved Steven Tyler. I had a-
- Yes, Steven Tyler for sure.
- [Kelly] I was like, "he doesn't know
we're gonna get married, but we are."
Yeah.
- Well, it's funny that it-
- I was the weird kid with
daddy issues, apparently.
(laughing)
- Well, when you watch The Reunion,
I was like, "oh, they
can like still get it."
I was like, that, it's been-.
- Oh, My God. They're
funny, they're witty.
Matt's been on here. Yeah, yeah.
They're funny. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They're funny, they're cute.
Like, I was like, "good for them."
- Well. B.J. Novak was recently at a bar
and a fan sent him Kelly
Kapoor's favorite drink.
That drink is a 7 and 7,
with 8 maraschino cherries,
sugar on the rim, blended if you can.
(laughing)
Have you ever had one of these drinks?
- Okay, So this is from an,
so I have never had one.
And this is from an
episode of "The Office."
So Kelly Kapoor likes this
most sugary drink of all time.
- [Kelly] Which I am into.
It's a good thing her name is
Kelly. We'd get along, yeah.
- So it's like a 7, 7
and 7, it's like 7 Up?
I don't know what the other 7 is.
- [Kelly] It's like a Seagram's
seven, is that what it is?
- [Mandy] Yeah, yeah,
Seagram's seven, 7 and 7
with seven maraschino cherries.
It's like disgusting.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- But be B.J. sent it,
and I've never had it,
but I've always, it sounds
disgusting but I was-
- But here's the thing.
If it's discussing,
we're going to find out,
because I made them.
(audience cheering and laughing)
- Yes!
So here we go.
- Thank you, Justin.
- Oh, my God, thank you. Wait.
- Oh wait, I love, blended if you can.
- Oh, my God here, cheers.
- It is blended.
- Fully blended.
- Wait, the sugar on the rim.
That's a different pink.
- I'm going to get some.
- Oh, my God.
- Okay.
- Mm Hmm. Just giving me diabetes.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God. It's just like, straight up
like a like a snow cone or slushy.
- This tastes delicious.
- It's like, it's like a snow cone.
- This is like something
that you would get.
First of all, this feels like
a child would like to
drink this, which is bad-
- My daughter is gonna
to see this and be like,
"why didn't you bring it home?"
- Why didn't you bring it home?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Um, this is like something they would
have at Universal CityWalk, like...
(laughing)
- And then I would
definitely get it and say
it's for my kids, but
really drink it myself.
What? No one does that.
- Thank you, Kelly for my awesome 7 and 7.
- Your first drink, it's yours.
(audience cheering)
Well, now that we have our drinks,
Um, Reese Witherspoon asked you to write
Legally Blonde 3, which I
gotta be honest with you.
I'm very excited about that.
(audience cheering)
I love the movies, but
I'm such a fan of you
and like your humor and your twist on it.
I'm so stoked for it.
Were you just freaking out?
- [Mandy] Thank you.
Well, I feel like I'm
writing a Marvel movie.
Because it's like, it's
like, it's Reese's Avengers.
You know, it's like her beloved character.
(Kelly laughing)
And like, she's like, you
know, Elle woods is like,
for people like me love romantic comedies,
Elle woods is like Captain America.
So, I was such a fan
and then they were like,
"would you like to write the movie?"
And I feel like I'm writing fan fic, like-
- I love it.
- [Mandy] I'm just like, but I-
- Is it fun? It's different though, right?
Like-
- Yeah, I mean, I just
love the first movie.
it's so perfect.
So it's really fun,
but it's also daunting.
But it's really fun thinking
of like Elle Woods at,
you know, 43 or whatever.
What is her life like?
What, did she have kids?
- But what I think is
interesting is like all of like,
our age women, like we we've
gone through those stages.
So we're like the same.
So it's nice to see.
It's kind of cool.
I think all those same
fans are going to be like,
"what's happening now."
- [Mandy] Kelly? I hope so.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I will totally watch.
I love, I love them.
I think they're so great.